[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es mal ein
außerplanmäßiges video weil ich sehe
überall diesen dallgow nach kaffee und
ihr wisst ja ich bin ein riesen koffer
junkie und ich musste jetzt einfach mal
ausprobieren
ich bin ja eigentlich so der latte
macchiato fan latte macchiato aber jetzt
probieren wir das mal und zwar ist das
eigentlich ein rezept ich das ist
eigentlich kein rezept das ist einfach
so drei trends aus drei bestandteilen
und zwar haben wir hier möglich ist
kaffeepulver es kommt jetzt direkt in
die schüsse dann haben wir hier noch
zucker und heißes wasser gerade
aufkochen lassen es gibt jetzt auch da
rein und dann wird das ganz einfach
verrührt ich nehmt also ihr könnt auch
eine maschine nehmen das ja kein problem
würde sogar schneller gehen aber ich
nehme jetzt einfach mal den schnäbeln so
und jetzt die ganze zeit umrühren und
irgendwann wird es mega cremig
wamser rührt seht euch das mal an wo ich
deswegen teilt uns ja auch die risse ich
will die ganze zeit hier im raum gewesen
mit meinem arm ja das war richtig
anstrengend genug nein nein und er jetzt
habe ich hier so eine richtig schöne
luftige masse schaut euch das mal an
schönheit cremig und eigentlich machen
wir jetzt nur noch folgendes wir nehmen
uns jetzt zwei gläser mit eiswürfeln und
ebenfalls ganz einfach mit rein das
mache ich jetzt hier direkt ihr könntet
auch cacau neben es auch eine gute idee
also nimmt auch gerne mit gerne auch
heiße milch und dann das kalt gewordene
diesem tal kommen schauen darauf auch
sehr geil so dann geben wir das einfach
nur noch drauf und das war es schon
das war's haben sie das ist es gewesen
deswegen sage ich das ist kein rezept
streng genommen und jetzt einmal drauf
[Musik]
so und jetzt einfach nur noch genießen
muss zur decke aus und natürlich an die
umwelt denken deswegen schickt hier auch
einen glas strohhalm und dann
schließlich das jetzt schön aus das war
jetzt nur mäßig aber muss sich das dann
halt so ein bisschen verrühren es sieht
einfach cool aus muss man dazu sagen so
ein tipp topp das ist cool aus wir haben
aber ich genau wo ich mich also nicht
besonders wahrscheinlich also schon die
milch überwiegt halt mega aber wenn ihr
das verrührt doch dann schmeckt echt
lecker
also ist man weiß ja wie es schmeckt im
prinzip ist es ja wirklich nur löslicher
kaffee mit viel zucker und milch ist
einfach nur das außen ja das aussehen
hier zählt mal das aussehen so so ist es
jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz viel freude
beim nachbarn probiert gerne mal
ausschreibt meine kommentare welchen
trend ich als nächstes machen so wir
haben uns herum markiert uns genau wir
hatten das sinne wenn brad dann hatten
wir auch jetzt schon meine haare
das zu einem anwalt das war auch ein
tick tock trend dann hatten wir jetzt
dass hier
und dann das dritte dass du dir jetzt
entscheiden aber es ist auch nicht so
groß ist
tik tok trend sind irgendwie nie
wirklich auf wahrnehmen egal jetzt
verabschiede ich mich und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten video teure kicken
[Musik]